mike we have to talk i know and i
thought we were done with this
vanderbilt
i really thought we were done with sarah
fuller but
i have an boy do i have an article to
read for you
female kicker on vanderbilt football
team explains why she was
pissed off at players and details her
halftime speech
get ready for this speech get ready
why do you get it you're not ready for
this did kedarius johnson get a speech
female soccer goalkeeper sarah fuller
was used as a fill-in kicker for the
men's vanderbilt football team on
saturday booting the ball 30 yards in
the opening kickoff of the second half
booting fuller was quickly hailed as a
hero by the mainstream and gave a
post-game interview with espn reporter
courtney corin
about her experience according to fuller
she insisted on giving a half-time
speech
and told the male players that she
wasn't afraid to call them out for not
cheering each other on
i i i am i'm sorry oh my god
a negotiation that apparently left her a
little pissed off she says
i'm converting to islam fuller only
started practicing with the men's team
tuesday
and she she needed to make the halftime
speech
so you don't want to be a
can you imagine a male fill-in kicker
coming in on a team on a tuesday and
saying i want to make the halftime
speech you know what they would tell him
shut the [ __ ] up and no i'm sorry you
know what right no not right you you
continue i'm just gonna face east if i
could sure you could spaces i'm
listening to the story though but please
please keep going
if i'm going to be honest
i was a little pissed off about how
quiet everyone was on the sideline
[Music]
fuller told corinne villa zoom call
outside
outkick reported so this is what she
said because i'm going to be honest i'm
a little pissed off about how quiet
everyone was on the sideline fuller told
cronin via zoom call out kick reported
we made a first down and i was the only
one
cheering and i was like what the heck
what's going on
and i tried to get them pumped and i was
like you guys need to start cheering
your team on
they haven't won a game this year and
they lost the game 41-0
why would they be cheering them on but
anyway my main thing was during the sec
tournament when she was
talking about her soccer which was in
the female soccer team my entire team
was cheering the entire time she
continued
it didn't matter if we were in the
locker room or if they were on the
sidelines i think that's what wanted for
us everybody was cheering non-stop
did she think cheer because the team is
not cheering is the reason the team
hasn't won a game this year and the
reason they lost 41-0
i mean yes because she just said it
basically women are
f oh my god i just went in there and i
said exactly what i was thinking fuller
explained i was like
we need to be cheering each other on
this is how you win games this is how
you get better by calling each other out
for stuff i'm going to call you guys out
did they call out her terrible squib
kick
her terrible 30-yard kick did they call
her 30-yard kick that was terrible
no because she was cheering everybody on
we're all about positivity rice
i think this team has struggled and
that's been part of it diagnosed fuller
we really just need to build that team
camaraderie oh goodness and all lean on
each other so she's a coach now too this
is great
this is oh my god every [ __ ] time
you people tell me that i'm out of line
for the [ __ ] i say about women
every like at what point do i get
[ __ ] people to say you know what
marsh you were right you were right
they're terrible they're
you can't give them an inch they will
take 10 miles every single time
we really just need to build the team
camaraderie uh where they can
and call and can all lean on each other
it was an adjustment
going from the team mentality where hey
we're all here supporting one another
and i just want to bring this team out
uh i hope i gained their respect so can
i ask do you think she gave their
respect mike well let me ask you
something because
it sounds and i don't want to be out of
line here i certainly don't want to yes
you do
be disrespectful to the wrong genders
here uh
but what it sounds like to me is that
she wants to be a cheerleader
that's the problem though mike this is
what she looks like so she can't be a
cheerleader i get it
but it sounds like she wants to so she
can't be a flag girl
mm-hmm oh yeah she could be a flat girl
you're right you want to get the [ __ ]
you want to get them going how about you
join
band how about you join the band yeah
[ __ ] why like you see my point like
you you finally got on the team but your
female instincts are kicking in
which is to clap and cheer while the men
do the work so
why don't you just do the position
that's been there for you for a hundred
years
for to clap and cheer while the men do
the hard part and get cte
and [ __ ] and shorten their lifespans
you know what i mean like
you can't ever be on that field when
some real shit's going down
it's the same thing with a female
firefighter or a female
marine you you're never gonna be at the
tip of the [ __ ] spear
you're gonna be in the back doing supply
or or doing [ __ ] motor pool and
you're gonna be getting [ __ ] you know
what i mean
you're not getting an infantry [ __ ]
mos but you know what you are gonna do
you're gonna do supply and you're gonna
sit in the rear
in the rear with the gear and then
you're gonna do your four years and
you're gonna get out and you're gonna
i was a marine hey i thought i was a
[ __ ] marine
okay and it's the same thing with this
[ __ ] this broad is gonna get paraded
around on people's shoulders like
she's a football star no she's not it's
a gimmick
she's a [ __ ] gimmick that's all it is
it's it's a um
like tebow playing on the mets practice
team yeah exactly
it's it's triple a team it's just it's a
gimmick it's a [ __ ]
attraction it's something that you go
whoa we're breaking out the female
kicker
but nobody gives a [ __ ] like nobody's
ever said oh [ __ ] man
we almost lost the battle but then all
[ __ ] sarah fuller showed up
and boy did the tide turn it's never
happened
uh she continued i hope i gained their
respect
it wasn't ill-intentioned at all it was
this t it just i just want this team to
succeed and do well fuller added
i'm a vanderbilt student athlete i want
all our sports to succeed i call it how
i see it
she takes no guff hey mike you know
where the rule book is out the window
with her
uh i know she's a kicker i call it how i
see it and i'm not going to bs anybody
it didn't want to bs them
she said i had coaches come up to me and
say i've been wanting to see that for a
while now the athlete claimed
that never happened things that things
that never happened
500. and that's the other thing dude you
can't you you can't even call a woman
out when they make some [ __ ] up like
that because then you're attacking women
like what happened to like whatever
happened to having
some some standards for for telling the
truth right like
this if there's one thing you want to
say about guys if
if you're around a group of guys right
and somebody comes in with some real out
of left field [ __ ] like a real
[ __ ] story
guys will call you out on that [ __ ] guys
police themselves very well even if
they're friends like you don't have to
dislike each other
you could be a group of friends hanging
out and your buddy could walk in and go
bro
i just had a threesome last night with
two models bro two [ __ ]
two models from maxim and you'd go no
you didn't no you didn't when did it
happen
where did you go to dinner what did you
have well the first time first off it
was maximum it was 2005.
true i'm sure they still have a web was
it fhm
i get it i'm old but the point being you
would you'd go no you
that didn't happen and you go no i
totally did yeah where'd you go
where'd you hang out all right what
hotel did it happen you'd start
hammering your buddy and when they
you go it didn't happen because you're a
lion sack of [ __ ] stop
[ __ ] lying but if you do that to a
girl they sob and then they run to the
[ __ ] dean and they go
but i can be a kicker and then they're
like ah my own he cry you take the fight
here's your football helmet
that's what happens fuller's 30-yard
so-called squip kick
made her the first female to appear in a
football game for a power five school
vanderbilt lost the game the missouri
41-0
but vanderbilt's losing because they're
not cheering enough by the way lucky
hack says nikki you fell asleep on the
couch eating cheetos after you smoked a
bowl
i did lucky you're 100 right and i could
still kick a ball more than 35 yards i'm
sorry
it's it doesn't we've been talking about
this before the show
any one of you could have taken me or
royce and i don't even mean like me and
royce
after a week of practice i mean just
pulling us out of the stands and went
kick this ball
i could have made the ball travel
farther than she did
again completely unex eating nachos and
drinking a beer and going
and a spotlight hits you and they're
like you sir
come on down and do the opening kick
anybody in this chat room could have kid
some of the girls in this chat room yeah
could have kicked the football better
than this bid
i'm sure executed could have made it up
to 40 yards yeah but then she would have
called everybody fat and controlled them
she just started calling everybody the
n-word and they would have had to have
her removed and maced